okay so now we have registered an app
engine project and we are almost ready
to do some coding but just before we do
that let's talk about supporting
different devices for a while one big
challenge when designing server-side
applications today is that there are so
many different devices from so many
different vendors that you need to
support different browsers smartphone
tablets and computer all having
different api's that should be used
initially we will be using the browser
for our course project but later we will
be able to support the mobile phone
without rewriting a single line of code
having to consider this when you design
your server-side application it's a lot
of work so how can we solve this problem
well the Google cloud platform has
solved this problem for you with a
product called Cloud endpoints when you
use Cloud endpoints you can create one
single API for your server application
called a Cloud endpoints API Cloud
endpoints can then generate the
client-side API for many different
devices for many different vendors this
is great of course because it allows you
to focus on your server-side application
and Cloud endpoints will make sure that
it supports many different devices you
will learn a lot more about Cloud
endpoints since we will use it when we
build out the course project enough said
we have now created an app engine
project using the developers console and
looked at the benefits of Cloud
endpoints it's time for you to get a
development environment up and running